.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME ON,
TUCKER.
>> Tucker: DEVON NUNEZ
ULTIMATELY LEFT THE HOUSE UNTIL
COMMITTEE.
ERIC SWALWELL SAYS HE'S BEING
DEJECTED FROM THE COMMITTEE OUT
OF PURE VENGEANCE, WATCH
FRACKING THE ONLY PERSON WHO
SUPPORTS THIS IS MY WIFE WAS
LIKE GREAT, YOU'RE GOING TO BE
HOME TO CHANGE MY DIAPERS, I
LOVE IT.
THE TRUTH IS, IT IS PURELY
VENGEANCE.
I WANT TO WALK YOUR VIEWERS
THROUGH THIS BECAUSE THIS
HAPPENED NEARLY TEN YEARS AGO.
THE FBI TOLD ME SOMEONE WHO HAD
BEEN HELPING OUR CAMPAIGN IN A
DISTRICT WITH 35 PERCENT ASIAN
AMERICANS MAY BE WORKING WITH
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT.
I DID WHAT I HOPE EVERYONE OF M
COLLEAGUES WOULD DO WHICH WAS T
HELP THE FBI GET THIS PERSON OU
OF THE COUNTRY.
ITS ONLY NOW THAT A TRUMP INTEL
OFFICIAL HAD LEAKED MY
COOPERATION TO SUGGEST THERE WA
SOME WRONGDOING ON MY PART.
>> IT IS JUST POLITICAL
VENGEANCE, BUT THAT'S NOT TRUE.
WHAT ACTUALLY HAPPENED IS
IMPORTANT FOR LAST DIRECTOR OF
NATIONAL INTELLIGENCE WENT TO
CAPITOL HILL AND BRIEFED THE
INTEL COMMITTEES ABOUT THE INTE
THREAD.
HE RECOMMENDED THAT A GANG OF
EIGHT THAT ERIC SWALWELL BE
REMOVED FROM THE HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE THE MOST SENSITIVE
COMMITTEE BECAUSE HE HAD BEEN
COMPROMISED BY CHINA.
THAT IS NOT AN OVERSTATEMENT
CHINESE SPY HELPED GET ERIC
SWALWELL ELECTED TO THE CONGRESS
, A CHINESE BY RAISED
MONEY FOR HIS CAMPAIGN.
A CHINESE CAMP ATTORNEYS BY PLA
STAFFERS IN HIS OFFICE.
BUT THE MAIN PROBLEM, THE MAIN
PROBLEM WITH THE INTEL COMMUNIT
HAD WITH ERIC SWALWELL, IS THAT
HE HAD WITH A CHINESE FIVE.
WE'VE MADE FUN OF HIM OVER THE
YEARS FOR THIS, BUT IT'S REAL.
SWALWELL HAS NEVER DENIED IT
BECAUSE HE CAN'T DENY IT AND
EVERYBODY WHO'S LOOKED INTO IT
KNOWS THAT IT'S TRUE.
WE'RE NOT HERE TO IF YOU ARE
HAVING W